Super Single both of you guys are super
single what is what's the difference
between single and Super
Single uh it could be raining men and I
would still be
single so it could so men are throwing
themselves at you but you're still
single yes okay and Bri like what does
that mean for you super single super
single as in I'm not
currently you know because like you can
be single and like I'm talking to this
person I'm seeing where it's going to go
and for me it's just
no like I single okay can I can I maybe
like take those two different sound
bites and maybe like kind of put them
through my mail brain and sort of tell
them back how I'm hearing you guys say
that because when I hear Super Single in
the way that you describe it it sounds
to me like there's absolutely nobody
right now that I have any interest in
and if a top shelf Man shows up I'm
in uh um yeah I think that's kind of I
feel like I'm just like I have I would
say that there's options but they're not
the options that I
want same thing for you P or yes as in
like you know you can be single and
dating and talking to somebody I don't
even have any hoes so that's what I mean
by Super Single what do you mean by I
don't have any hoes rotation no like
side pieces side pieces like I'm not
even talking to guy or dating anybody
like what are the problems because
there's lots of good-looking you know
successful guys out there like what's
happening for you I I guess I have
really bad luck or I'm cursed or
something someone put a spell on me or
something like oh I don't even know
where to start with the story as I was
telling Mo some of my
stories stories you know you're live on
here so I've had a guy whip out a tuna
sandwich in the middle of a date and
then tell me that he needs to stop for
rope duct tape and a bowling ball to
kidnap me which I didn't find funny like
I can't stuff up he whipped out a tuna
sandwich yes and said he needs duct tape
and a bowling ball to kidnap you and
rope yeah he needs to stop because we
were driving and you were in his car or
you or he in car I was in his car and he
stopped he didn't just eat the tuna
sandwich in the go he he stopped at the
gas station where you can't park to eat
a stuna sandwich it was so awkward
I mean there's there's awkward and
anxious guys there that out there that
just aren't calibrated to what women
respond to there's no question about
that um I mean guys run into some really
bizarre women too at the same time but I
mean I've heard a lot of stories about
some weirdos out there but that's that's
not all of them I mean there's some
genuinely decent dudes out there I mean
you're cross in any of these guys that
are together they've got their money
squared away they're successful they're
influential they're competent they're
not
boring you're not seeing any of these
dudes when you're dating no I haven't
met any you must be meeting them at gun
ranges though like you know if you're if
you're shooting guns there's usually
typically masculine men that that that
do that like that's a that's a strong
male Pursuit right like you don't
generally see dorks and dweebs doing
stuff like that um I haven't met too
many in well in that's why in the states
I found I don't know there's cooler men
in the states I get it like the grass is
not always greener but uh I don't know
Canadian can indan men I haven't found
um any here because the just lot of
weird stories what part of Canada are
you in um right now western Canada okay
all right um I've lived in Toronto so
okay um Bri what's your what's your
experience been like with uh dating guys
is it similar to what P's describing
like you're getting some awkward anxious
guys for the most part that aren't
calibrated or like what's happening like
why why why are you also Super Single uh
I think I'm just too picky I don't give
my time to people like if I feel like
you know or you can kind of guess where
like which direction they're looking for
or if it's a good fit or not pretty much
right off the bat there's exceptions to
that of course but I don't know I just
don't want to waste my
time so that's I'm just too picky if I
remember you're on a military base too
right so you're dealing with a lot of
military
um what and this is a question for both
of you but what are the like the top
five characteristics that you're looking
for in a guy so that he can take you off
the Super Single sort of
status
[Music]
um I need somebody that is ambitious so
if they tell me they have a goal then I
need like they need to be able to like
work towards that goal you know somebody
that can take care of themselves
um
and see topid I don't really when you
say take care of themselves you mean
like self-care like physical take care
of themselves like they got to be
attractive but I mean I feel like being
attractive especially on dating apps
like you know you're not going to swipe
right on somebody you don't find
attractive yeah um so that is like the
first step of it but take care of them
themselves as in they are independent
and they're looking for or a girlfriend
potentially a wife not a second
mother okay so not a Manchild I guess is
what women usually call those guys yes
okay so I got ambitious so ambitious
like what does ambitious mean to you
like he's got to make a certain amount
of money no he just has to be able to so
if he says that oh I'm GNA do this this
is my life goal this is my fiveyear plan
but he's not making any steps you know
like a
have a vision and take actions to get
there otherwise it's it's just a dream
and you're all talk so I want to get a
little more focused on ambition to a
specific number because saying like
there's lots of guys out there that'll
that'll hold out to the public that
they're ambitious they got big plans I'm
going to develop this business I've got
this business idea it's a million-dollar
business blah blah blah and that sort of
stuff but like you kind of alluded to
like I want to see something like I want
to see something factual I want to see
some results I want to see some traction
some forward movement like what's
happening here like I've often said that
women do have a lot more patience for a
young 22y old guy that's hot that has
ambition and a plan but they have a lot
less patience for an older guy into his
30s and 40s that doesn't have anything
to show for for himself like if he
doesn't have a pot to piss in or a
window to throw it out of but he has
some sort of a plan and he's like 40
women tend to have a lot less patience
for a guy like that versus the 22y old
that's hot but still has a plan because
he's got more Runway ahead of him right
you see what I'm saying with that so as
far as the ambition notion goes like
there's got to be some sort of number in
your head that that he's got to be able
to to make in order to lock you down and
take your super single status off the
market so that um like you get to claim
each other you know if you know what I
mean like what is that 100 Grand is it
75 grand 150,000 like have you thought
about what the guy needs to
make no because I
don't I'm not don't you think that that
that's important though to sort of like
hash that
out yes I don't want to put just like oh
I'm only going to talk to you if you
make $100,000 or more because that's
very superficial and I don't think that
I'm a superficial person I just want you
know you have your own place you have
your own vehicle you take care of your
Bells you are able to if we do end up
getting married like I don't want to be
drowning in your debt like take care of
yourself in that aspect of things so
he's got to be at least equivalent to
you
financially yes I do not want to be a
bread winner which I'm a teacher so I
don't really think that's too difficult
okay what about you P like what's your
what's your idea of like ambition or
financial stability you know income
earning ability stuff like that like how
do you look at
that um like someone who's not lazy
always doing stuff
um in also intelligent like intelligent
is one my top five because I don't want
to feel like I'm talking to a wall or
having conversations with myself um
because I don't know I feel like Society
is dumber nowadays
so I really want someone intelligent
what's that word that they use to
describe being attracted to
intelligence
um they call saposexual saposexual yeah
saposexual have you ever heard of that
yes yes I just forgot the term what the
term
was okay so so you're looking for a guy
that exhibits intelligence if he's
intelligent if he can have a great
conversation with you he's a Chessmaster
he understands all of Einstein's
theories of Relativity and so on but he
only makes $40,000 a year is that enough
for
you uh it depends if he has the other
qualities like it's not just
intelligence same with it's not just
attractiveness I don't care how hot a
guy is like if that's all he has and
he's not intelligent or a nice person or
possesses empathy or is honest then I'm
not interested so hang a sec h a sec
give those qualities again so not lazy
intelligent hotness doesn't matter but
but he's got empathy what else were the
other
ones uh honesty honesty
okay like uh like yes I need to be
physically attracted to somebody but
that's not all that matters because
again I've found people that I'm
physically attracted to but I'd rather
talk to a wall or watch paint
dry because they're just so boring or
just not interested in or just their
attitude or like yeah okay so let's do
this to sort of clarify because you
mentioned hotness doesn't matter but you
said that you've got to be attracted to
him so on a scale of 1 to 10 with 10
being like the hottest and one being
like absolutely not even close to
remotely hot what does he have to be at
least for
you
uh that's a hard one to say CU if we
look at my I have to be honest because
if we look at my dating history I don't
exactly pick the the eight to 10
so I'd say like uh over a
five five's pretty above average I know
it's pretty low like I it's a pretty low
bar bar the way that you're describing
so here's where I'm confused because
you're saying that you can't be lazy
he's got to be intelligent he's got to
be at least a five he's got to be empath
itic and be honest I can guarantee you
right now there's probably just about
everybody watching the show would be
like yo I took off that box can I call
you I can't narrow it down to five
qualities these to have energy too you
know match your Vibe match your energy
like I have natural human crackhead
energy I don't drink alcohol or C coffee
or caffeine what is what is natural
human crackhead
energy think of the energize your bunny
yeah energize your bunny as a human yeah
energy that matches yours you're
saying yes but not quite to the point
where I'd want to kill them if you know
what I
mean that could beine this is you off
any stim stimulants caffeine anything
like that this is no yeah I don't drink
I don't drink alcohol coffee caffeine
nothing yeah so this is you like this is
your normal this is your off-the-wall
kind of very energetic person okay and
you you like somebody that's G to be
that matches that or would you prefer a
guy that's maybe a little more on the
laidback side because I think because we
T we tend to kind of find these yin and
yang right so it's like if I think two
people I think if you had a guy that
matched your energy and that was just as
offthe wall I think you'd be exhausted I
think that would be
insane yeah like someone who can help
bring me back like not quite like me but
someone who can obviously like they they
can they put up with it because I'm not
me and my energy is not for everybody I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out